but but I think there's an important
contextual difference which is that
Jason and his wife aren't saying like go
do this and it'll be fine what they're
saying was like this was a horribly
damaging thing to do she wished she had
never done it and she repented and got
close to Christ and like did the work to
undo her scars and if it's genuine sure
but I just think like the issue like why
I think a lot of times Church like
attracts women that like hat like that
are a bit slug I mean come on like let's
just be honest like there's a reason
those Catholic girls have a reputation
there's a reason Church girls have a
reputation well I think because most
people are who are supposedly raised in
the faith aren't they're told they're
Catholic and they don't go to church
they don't well I I think it's two
because like the church kind of sells
them dreams that you can do all this
stuff and still have a guy waiting for
you at the end